Freunde es ist ein neuer Player im Game
es gibt einen neuen Lieferdienst hier in
meiner Heimatstadt Köln das ist immer
ein Event für mich ich habe das bei
Freddy gesehen also bei sturmwaffel der
hat das ganze schon getestet ist mir
diesmal zuvorgekommen Freddy ich habe
extra nicht das ganze Video geschaut
weil ich möchte natürlich überrascht
werden Circus heißt der ganze Spaß und
die Besonderheit ist es gibt Gerichte
nur für drei sechs und neun Euro ist
würde ich fast sagen wenn die Portion
angemessen sind relativ günstig deshalb
gucken wir uns das ganze einfach mal an
wir sehen direkt hier oben funky Falafel
Bowl und Peter Brad sind scheinbar die
absoluten Bestseller falafelbaum 9 €
Peter red 3 €. was haben wir denn sonst
noch so empfohlen Pasta und Gnocchi
bowls und Salat Kategorien Burgers und
Bauhaus Preis Currys Pizza Snacks und
sights desert to share und Kids es
klingt sehr gut und das Interessante ist
das habe ich bei Freddy im Video gehört
dass die scheinbar mit Ghost kitchens
Arbeiten falls ihr das nicht kennt das
bedeutet in Restaurant Küchen wird für
diesen Lieferservice hergestellt also
anders als bei Volt bei Lieferando bei
uber-eats wir das vielleicht kennt
bestellt man nicht beim Restaurant Pizza
Bella Italia sondern man bestellt direkt
bei Circus beim Lieferdienst und der
kümmert sich irgendwie magisch das aber
auch Ghost kitchen darum dass das zu
euch nach Hause kommt und immer die
gleiche Qualität haben soll falls ihr
Beast Burger kennt von MR Beast das ist
genau das gleiche Prinzip es gibt auf
jeden Fall die ein oder andere Sache die
ich gerne testen möchte deshalb fangen
wir direkt mal an zu bestellen Benchmark
Burger wir müssen den Burger bestellen
bin ich ganz ehrlich Leute classic
Veggie beef Burger classic Veggie finde
ich auch schon interessanter täglich ich
glaube das ist generell so ein
großstadtding wenn ihr jetzt nicht in
der Großstadt wohnt dann wird es
wahrscheinlich bei euch auch noch kein
Circus geben bei uns ist das alles auch
komplett neu ich würde glaube ich so den
Classic testen den Classic Reggie beef
Burger habe ich mir einmal rein
interessant 9,99 €. warum der 9,99 €
warum gibt dir was für 7,99 €.
vielleicht habe ich auch bei Freddy
falsch aufgenommen aber ich glaube die
werden auch damit Preis Pommes ganz
ehrlich nicht leicht zu liefern werden
übelst schnell so weich und sie sind
schlau es gibt nämlich keine einfachen
Pommes sondern es gibt Pommes immer nur
mit Soße überladen so dass sie sowieso
zappig ankommen scharfe chicken freies
[Musik]
9,00
€ 6,9 Euro und wie ist das nur bei
Burger ein bisschen anders haben die
auch haben sie alle 9 €. ja was gibt's
denn hier überhaupt für 3 € Salat kostet
auch sechs Euro kostet nur Peter Brot 3
€ bisher Party potato sweets chocolate
Browny 3 €
bekommens großes vegetarisches Angebot
das ist natürlich auch gut die ist 3600
€ habe ich komplett falsch verstanden
für 15 € big shits alle zwei bis vier
Personen oder habe ich alles drauf das
ist auch das würde ich niemals bestellen
beim Lieferservice ich habe so irgendwie
das Gefühl dass die so ehrliche Gerichte
anbieten irgendwie schon oder so home
cooking Style solche Gerichte die man
sich so zu Hause machen würde aber die
man so in dieser lieferwelt gar nicht
sieht das stimmt schon Party potatoes wo
sehen wir sowas in dieser ganzen
lieferwelt wir haben Italiener da
draußen wir haben verschiedene
Lieferservice ist die Grillgerichte
anbieten Perser oder was auch immer
vielleicht ist das eine Nische die hier
fühlen uns noch eine Pinsel raus 9 €
finde vielleicht vier weil die sieht
echt nicht groß aus was mich auch frage
wenn man jetzt da so bestellt und
bestellen verschiedene Dinge ob die dann
auch aus verschiedenen kitchen so
zusammengetragen werden
einmal dazu sehr scharf und ein carem
damit sind wir bei 40 € für einen Burger
Pommes Spätzle Kartoffelpüree
den pinser und ein chocolate Brownie
kann man machen jetzt gucken wir mal wie
das Ganze wirklich ankommt ob es
ausreichend ist ob es gut ist wir sehen
uns gleich wieder so die Bestellung ist
angekommen ich habe ein bisschen
nachgeforscht das ganze wurde in einer
Küche gekocht nicht von einem Restaurant
was zusätzlich noch das kocht so wie das
bei den Beast Burger immer ist sondern
quasi wirklich in einer Lage Einheit
industrieküchen draußen alles verdunkelt
und innen drin wird gekocht ich finde
das kann einen schon so ein bisschen
fraglich stimmen wenn man einfach nur
hört okay das wird in irgendeiner Ghost
kitchen zubereitet Kollege von uns von
ganz in der Nähe von einer aber das hier
sieht schon mal nicht verkehrt aus
Lieferung war ziemlich genau nach 38
Minuten ist aber verglichen mit woll z.B
ja auch super Platz sind nicht super
schnell probieren wir
geil ich weiß nicht mal wie das hier an
der Stelle sagen muss aber ich bin auf
jeden Fall nicht gesponsert von denen
oder so sondern habe einfach weil ich
dachte cooles neues Video das ganze
gemacht es gibt die auch bis dato nur in
Hamburg und Köln jetzt relativ neu das
ist ein richtig geile Sache für jemand
der noch nicht Pinsel gegessen hat ist
im Prinzip eine Pizza ich finde es macht
kaum Unterschied sondern eine andere
Form
Spitzenklasse muss man wirklich sagen
der ist fluffig ja diese geile Tiefe im
Geschmack also für gelieferte Pizza sehr
gut nicht mehr super heiß aber gerade
diese Ausführung mit Chili hier oben
drüber so dass man so richtig so was
merkt beim Essen liebe ich unheimlich
schmeckt auch traditionell so das ist
eine sehr sehr gute Ausführung einer
lieferpizza Kostenfaktor 9 €, wenn man
jetzt mal so eine Standard 32 cm
lieferpizza nimmt würde vielleicht in so
einer Ausführung die haben vielleicht so
11 € Kosten ist deshalb nicht wirklich
günstiger würde ich jetzt einfach mal
sagen hier
wäre sonst noch normale Pizza deshalb
also ich glaube das kommt aus gleicher
raus ist jetzt nicht unbedingt günstiger
aber besser weil das ist eine echt gute
lieferpizza
Pinter greife einfach mal beherzt rein
und ich habe den Classic Beat Burger
bekommen viel free to ready and freshy
guckt bei den was Code outside okay auch
geil interessant wir haben auch
herausgefunden die Firma im Hintergrund
ist eine deutsche Firma auch wenn alles
auf Englisch getrimmt ist ganz ähnlich
wie auf dem Kanal
riecht ganz stark nach beyond meat auf
jeden Fall auch kein Burger Band von der
Stange die sind nicht so konvext sondern
die sind einfach wie so ein Zylinder
oben drauf boah schöne karamellisierte
Zwiebeln Gurke der Käse sieht ein
bisschen geschmolzen ne Käse sieht
bisschen suspekt aus ganz schön
angetoastet sieht relativ
vielversprechend aus aber auch hier
entscheidet er Geschmack der Burger ist
eigentlich nicht wirklich durchgeweicht
das darf man glaube ich erwarten wenn
das ein Konzept ist was auf andere
Städte übertragen wird skaliert wird
dass das lieferkonzept auch wirklich gut
ist probieren wir
wir haben gefühlt viel Bann so dass es
etwas trocken sein könnte ist dem so
sind viele viele Soßen drauf also es ist
schon eine saftige Angelegenheit auch
das Patty selbst ist sehr saftig drauf
ich bin mir fast sicher das Bier ist
oder was ähnliches also so schmeckt auf
jeden Fall Bier und Meeting credible ich
wollte es wirklich nicht so gerne mögen
wie ich mag das ist echt überraschen
Alter ich habe mir das Video von Freddy
extra nicht angeschaut und unverein
genommen zu sein aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass er es nicht gut fahren
auch sehr schön richtig richtig gut Bro
Regie Burger wow das ist wirklich kein
bisschen schlechter als ein beef Burger
und geliefert das schon gar nicht Hammer
richtig gut glaube dass die diese
Qualität jetzt gerade halt anbieten
können weil die bestimmt viel Geld
eingesammelt haben als Startup was gut
vernetzt ist und so irgendwie macht für
mich gerade voll wenig Sinn dass das so
gut ist ist das hier jetzt so richtig
Kantine weil das war mein Gedanke ist
sieht auch bisschen Kantine aus
schon
was aus einer Tüte kommen könnte aber
auch
nicht probieren aber
ist relativ unemotional also bei den
anderen Sachen machen wir unsere krass
wow das ist halt einfach Kartoffelpüree
ist aber auch nur eine Beilage oder wird
schon eher sagen dass das nicht aus der
Tüte ist aber die Feinheit des Paris
spricht eigentlich schon dafür
als ob die so das so richtig krank durch
den Sieb drücken
next ab haben wir die Potato Wedges bzw
Fries die sehen wieder wirklich gut aus
wie viel haben die gekostet 9 €, ne das
war so ein klassischer neun Euro
versetzen ich bezahlen 9 € und kriege
das satt werde ich davon halt
wahrscheinlich nicht wenn ich richtig
Hunger habe verstehe ich mir noch was
für 3 € dazu dann bin ich wieder bei 12
€ pro Person ist dann auch wieder
relativ normal ich finde bei der
Qualität die wir bisher hatten und so
gut wie es geschmeckt hat muss es auch
nicht mehr als normal sein weil es halt
auf dem Preisniveau halt absolut
konkurrenzfähig ist probieren wir
einfach mal hier so ein potatch
die machen das natürlich nicht
unüberlegt dass sie halt alles so lautet
preismäßig machen weil wir sehen uns
auch hier die schwitzen hier schon ganz
schön in der Verpackung wäre auch
erfrischend zu sehen gewesen wenn die so
ein super cooles Pommes lieferkonzept
hätten mit dem man halt wüsste okay die
sind knusprig aber knusprig sind jetzt
nicht gehen wir mal anders haben
das schmeckt nicht so super fresh das
erinnert mich ein bisschen anders
Lufthansa Business Class backhandel was
im Ofen noch mal warm gemacht wurde
daran erinnert mich ein bisschen also
wir haben auf jeden Fall die Highlights
zu Beginn gehabt weil das hier ist mehr
wie so ein
Kartoffelsalat das ist so ein Tisch der
sieht so in der App ganz cool aus und
klingt auch nice aber dann kommt der an
und dann kann er nicht so richtig die
Erwartungen erfüllen oder schade nicht
schlecht aber für 9 € auch nicht
wirklich gut muss ich sagen also die
Pizza tschüss der Burger tschüss auf
eine letzte Sache bin ich noch sehr
gespannt bevor wir zum bisher kommen und
zwar die Spätzle mit Bacon und das
wollen wir jetzt prüfen ist es wirklich
so gut es sieht auf jeden Fall lecker
aus der Bacon ist auf dem ersten Blick
für Bacon Kenner schon mal so ein
kleiner Fake Bacon ich gehe aber direkt
rein nicht lange rum reden bisschen
späte
und wirklich soßig muss ich jetzt mal
ganz kurz vorweg nehmen sehen die
Spätzle nicht aus oder sind schon aber
du hast kein Mac and cheese ne sondern
Carbonara Spätzle hat es natürlich
erwartungsgemäß wenig mit einer
Carbonara zu tun Spätzle aber einen
geilen Biss und es ist schon auch
irgendwie ein perverses Gericht ne ich
meine man muss ja wissen worauf man sich
einlässt man bestellt sie dann halt
Spätzle mit einer Sahnesoße und Bacon
Chips obendrauf in der Ausführung her
auf jeden Fall sehr gelungen ist schon
so eine cremige Soße auf jeden Fall die
sparen auf jeden Fall nicht an Würze
oder alles ist richtig geil geworden
sich gewürzt nicht so vorsichtig
Carbonara Spätzle Kosten 6 €, ich finde
für 6 € vollkommen in Ordnung wir machen
am Ende ein kleines Ranking was meine
Favoriten waren fehlt noch eine Sache
und zwar der Camel chocolate Browny der
sieht aus wie man es erwartet weiß jetzt
nicht ob der selbst gebacken ist einfach
so ein großes Blech ist auf jeden Fall
sehr sehr schön saftig boah dazwischen
so eine Karamellschicht bisschen Walnuss
crumble sieht schon sehr gut aus
das habe ich auch länger nicht gegessen
Attacke
der sein Geld wert
verklebt einem den Mund komplett saftig
sehr geil kommen wir zum Ranking Platz 1
die pinser geteilter Platz 2 Brownie und
Burger Platz 3 die Spätzle und als
letztes Potato Wedges und Kartoffelpüree
insgesamt aber auf jeden Fall eine gute
Sache ich habe das Gefühl ich werde auch
hier im Büro mit meinen Freunden
vielleicht ein zwei Mal noch da
bestellen gerade die Pizza war wirklich
sehr gut heute vielleicht noch mal ein
Video sehen wo ich die übrigen
gerichtete teste die wir noch nicht
hatten schreibt in die Kommentare wie es
euch geht tschüss